like TI if you're fighting his TI and
you had what you know playing if your
song was playing you had like a bonus
and like strength and stuff
environmental disasters would like kick
on it was so fun yes it's kind of crazy
that no one's tried to recreate that
again I know I know oh it'd be so fun
these days yeah the song in my opinion
was Paul Wall sitting sideways because
it just happened
um like like you were the explosions
were always happening
yo I missed it wasn't it kid don't get
me wrong I thought that was like a
petition or something for Def Jam
something to come back am I bugging yeah
yeah it was to get so many retweets or
likes and they they I think they
trolling us because they haven't done
nothing since then yeah I feel like
there's got to be like people that they
would put as actual Fighters that's not
that they don't think that or giving
them issue that they know that they
can't bring back without those prey
people you know what I'm saying like
maybe some license in it